[Music]
good morning
it's Thursday May 31st and you just got
said hello to by Lindsay Robertson Hank
I'm very late updating today because the
yetis out of town and when the yetis
gone I kind of don't know what to do
with myself or how to schedule my time
and I had to go to a reading earlier and
then reading turned into dinner and
dinner turned into drinks and then all
of a sudden it's 10 o'clock and I'm like
I have to go I got to make a brother 2.0
video and then I got home and I was
still hungry and the Yeti and I have
made this deal that we will eat
everything that is in the refrigerator
before we leave New York so I had an
after-dinner meal that consisted of
frozen chicken vindaloo carrots ketchup
and Italian dressing Hank where do you
get off dissing Barack Obama that's not
cool
we tried to present a united front here
at brotherhood 2.0 but when you go and
say things like Barack Obama is merely
well-spoken and merely attractive I get
angry who you gonna vote for in 2008 if
not Barack Obama yes he has a problem
with liquid coal I agree that he has a
problem with wicked coal but a lot of
people have a lot of other problems that
are even more serious than that
he's smart maybe I'm biased as a
nerdfighter but I value intelligence
Hank I'd like to thank you for the Queen
random a random Oh rim to lava Ranma no
lava Hank I'd like to thank you for the
Queen Rama to love a song it rocked by
the way Hank thanks to commenter Ashley
I now know Queen random Olaf his first
name and it is a beauty Rabbo doe and
Rhiannon pointy merino why did you go by
rentable onna when she could have gone
by Rab odo and Rianna Queenie anima
Katya
in other news Hank I've been thinking
some about the Brotherhood 2.com website
I think it's time for Brotherhood 2.0 to
have a forum because the comments are
getting really confused and there's so
many of them and it's hard to read them
all at once and you don't know which is
about what and so Hank I challenge you
to make us a forum if the viewers are in
favor of that speaking of challenges
you've done a great job with the
songwriting challenge so far I mean I
really three for a loop with that
skipping Memorial Day thing but then you
did a great job writing a song in like
six hours about
random Bologna so I'm really proud of
you on the challenge front and now I've
challenged you again
and I can't help but feel like you know
you haven't challenged me much lately
I mean there's a lot of things I could
do for a challenge for instance you
could challenge me to eat six ounces of
yogurt which is worth to weight watchers
points and say ten seconds
nerdfighters is there better get it with
all my nose I don't have one of those
tongues Hank do you have one of those
tongues
maybe if I lower my nose no no Matt Oh
wipe and click Hank I'll see you
tomorrow